well hello welcome to YouTube I'm Greg
this is the real rejects brand I'm
Brienne brand from Miss movies on
YouTube and the Twitter and in this
movement Smith is going on this movies
dotnet miss IOSCO movies on kids
together Graham snapchat yep I forget
things we got a little delayed memory
hey I do i snapchat only with guys who
want pictures of my nips that's it okay
Ruth that's just the honest to god yeah
pledged $100 did you get pictures the
budget we are the baby not recently in
case you didn't know hey honest trailers
the social network we know a thing about
social networks yeah we do I have a
facebook no I don't don't go dumb friend
requests yeah yeah we don't have a
Facebook doesn't I don't know you I'm
probably not going to accept you it's
really my family's Yang's FML I interact
with and if you're a hot girl I know
your account as a bot so don't even try
you don't even try I don't have any hot
girls in my friend room well hey let's
do this people ask for it honest trailer
social network Street junkies is totally
cool with us watching them no problem
there okay Joe Bailey
before you see the ruby of an evil
fictional technology company see the
story of Facebook a real life people
think about the social network that
revenue in those experience the world's
smartest film about the world's dos
premise if you answer affirmatively when
Tyler and Cameron Winklevoss and Divya
Narendra asked you to build harbor
connection v you say yes in this large
Shakespearean drama about the website
you're crazy and post minion means on
that uses snappy dialogue guy deserve
your attention you have part of my
attention you have the minimal amounts
like and recoup what it is to make a
story we're young millionaires to each
other for more money feel really high
stakes
what would your honor ship can dilute it
down to 0-3
person that's still millions agree oh
god that's not like kiddie 4.0 or 3% of
Neopets journey to Harvard where no one
ever lets you forget it's harder it's
John Hartman for gentleman from Hartford
Charles one again guys inaudible partner
Harvard Harvard Harvard this is Harper
and Mark Zuckerberg a star student with
a mind of a calculator the heart of the
troll Erica Albright to pitch and the
Wardrobe of a company hobo he's
determined to do some things with his
life make a world respected and make
sure Jesse Eisenberg gets every awkward
no donor goal in Hollywood
take that Michael Cera session applause
ears wide
Eduardo the only Brazilian who doesn't
know how to party is a good idea
see maybe you should shrink down before
we get into trouble you want to end the
party health until a peaceful person
Sean Parker does man on the side who
gets in the way of their romance and
don't we go by who briefly got your
hopes up that Armie Hammer had an
identical twin or to put it another way
let's go the dumb spider-man for NSYNC
and this is off the Lone Ranger if you
want to know the real slow behind
Facebook want something else because
they're bending the truth harder than
that
in a film that makes up the
ex-girlfriend is supposedly inspired the
site makes up an obsession with final
clubs that tears marks friendships apart
Tony this isn't about me getting into
the Phoenix and make them into an
awkward scowling robot we're in real
life he was a normal dorky college kid
within a couple of weeks to various
organs on down so at that point my
roommates you know this is pretty fully
whether the supportive schools said hey
let facts get in the way
I'm sure the real Sean Parker loves
seeing himself as apparently cooked up
cowardly maybe sort of statutory rapist
totally something like that shuttle over
there so gather well it's not really
about Facebook it's about friendship
that still there's what it's like and
use the website in this masterpiece of
crap and proves aaron sorkin could make
boring litigation excitement than a
festival or whole goddamn idea david
fincher can make apply for an internship
look awesome
and Trent Reznor could make rolling down
a calm river feel of age
[Music]
man I wish they'd make another Facebook
movie as the Senate I'd never thought
I'd say this live daughter story
Jesse Eisenberg as himself Andrew
Garfield for brazilian jiu tin from
Jurassic Park
the average temperature wrapping system
is nice and up to gave their lives so
David Fincher is get the pie chart cyclo
I know it's realistic and everything but
trying to understand Sorkin dialogue and
a lab bar it's like your grandma trying
to understand how Facebook works no Nana
sir story's not the same as the status
update thanks for watching
from here - trailers and let us know
what would you like to see get the bonus
treatment in the comment okay if you
guys were the inventors of Facebook you
know they vetted Facebook right Danny
Phantom she was just 14 when his parents
got a Springs machine I've got to get
back back to the past
Samurai Jack Lew who I of a gun I tuned
in to honest trailers we got a week
waiting for my comment to be read out I
just want my mother to be proud
do we have to student we to get her a
comment I don't know
they'll probably see our name of your
life we don't need to put them up I
think it goes into the comment section
here oh it's not on the Twitter will you
say what are we going to say everyone
please say something my racist huh yeah
Robert zero get with the hero from Kulas
ice that's what you wanna actually get
this day fine
do your would drop the zero get with a
hero that's that's fine okay that's fine
perfect we did a little bit I read
don't I mean over the real region
accounts say your worst yeah this is
technically say technically saying then
yeah
or make a statement really quick you
know how a few months ago we shot for a
movie versus movie segments on screen
Yogi's plus yeah you and Stacy had your
episode go up a while ago
yeah they release their episodes they
shot on screen junkies plus like every
two months or something like they really
spread them out it's in a while and my
episode with Roth Cornett and John
Flixster are still not up ever have a
long do something what's going on
stranger that was a while ago you know
what they're saving the best for last
for their last whole career oh I think
our last episode baby and I were
definitely like the last one they felt
you show that's why I'm like I have to
who I don't know questioning myself did
I do something wrong it's creepy just
because we sing the opening to bring in
a that's right well that was that was
really funny that was really really
funny but sure what I like the
perspective they're putting it into this
could have easily been a dull movie they
had to change a lot of facts in order to
make it not a dull movie that was one of
the big outcry as I remember the film
was this movie is so inaccurate to how
these people really are but even more
Zuckerberg said himself like it's really
entertaining some of them like not not
not accurate room but it's really
entertaining actually Jesse Eisenberg
did launch him into the like the serious
Michael Cera version I was thinking this
is considered a biopic but it's not
because just one section of his life so
still be a biopic I think it's about the
Missouri Berserker burg and the birth of
Facebook and like the meet of
ex-girlfriend's is that they're talking
about here you know Justin Timberlake
he's he was one of my favorite parts of
this film he was actually good you know
I remember seeing him in this movie
called model behavior which I believe
came out on like ABC Family or the
Disney Channel I'm not sure which one
not but it was owned by Disney and it
was kind of like where two girls look
alike so they switch roles and one of
them's like
a kind of a movie star and the other
ones just some average girl that goes to
high school and also it's a Pied Piper
or whatever that way you call it my
Trading Places or you know something
like that
hi Piper is a lot of our friends yeah
there we go
The Prince and the pauper hi Piper's
what they're about creating in Silicon
Valley okay
yeah mr. C can you watch a chef no well
that's the name of their company and I
eliminate evil icon now you lived in
Silicon Valley that's right girl laughs
this wasn't in Silicon Valley hence is
one of the biggest social networks in
the world you grew up in Silicon Valley
huh hmm well carny the show Silicon
Valley bunch of douche bags out there
now it is oh yeah and the thing with
Armie Hammer I'm having a twin I thought
it was twins when I watched the movie I
really thought of which twins is amazing
work they put out something great here
about the whole collaborative team
behind us because the idea of the
startup of Facebook and the way it was
told could sound like it could be a dull
film but you get an Aaron Sorkin strip
awesome David Fincher directing who
normally does like crime thrillers and
then he directs this like a crime
thriller but it's not music oshrin
resinar all these elements were like
David Fincher can do all kinds of work
but I especially Trent Reznor doing
music for a film and David Fincher they
shot this like it was a gritty crime
through and when it's when it's not but
that makes a big a din what makes the
movie so impactful and I know David
Fincher's a very peculiar director like
I wouldn't be surprised that they did
smash a billion laptops or that one shot
Jake Gyllenhaal said working on so the
act is pretty well known that him and
Fincher like started not getting along
Fincher would just do take after Taylor
on dances Ford Coppola
yeah the French are a couple of Stanley
Kubrick times were just like non-stop
take we're not even acting anymore and
Jake Gyllenhaal so it was just so
exhausting and both it was messing with
its crap I was actually letting Jake
Gyllenhaal's one of the best actors
around a little the best register
perhaps I really wish they would do it
interesting
African seeing those different tapes of
Andrew Garfield smashing and won't laugh
Tom I could only imagine how much money
was spent on destroying a laptop I
remember before the social network was
released and when it was in
pre-production before I think probably
had things by Aaron Sorkin and Davidson
drew attached and I used to do this show
called the film vault and my job on the
film ball was so pitch it's a podcast
and it's two pitched movies that are in
development and then they pretend that
they're the studio heads the two guys
and they'll say a red light or green
light the project and so I pitched the
social network because I pitch real
things that are in development and
sometimes things get made sometimes they
don't and I know one guy said he'd green
light and the other ones like no that's
on pouring red light and I and then a
seminary like that was my favorite yeah
my husband is now mark zuckerberg last
week what do you know where it was up in
San Jose cuz he was there for it's
called f8 which is Facebook 8 not a
period where they had his old television
and he's like he just walked back Wow
500 people were following yeah Jesse
Eisenberg's portrayal of Mark Zuckerberg
is exactly Jesse Eisenberg's portray a
little more because anytime I'm Xiomara
Berg and interviews or whatever or like
these hangouts up I don't know what Mark
Zuckerberg like in real life when a
camera's not pointed I have to sleeps
and not come across like the way Jesse
Eisenberg I love Jesse Eisenberg in the
social network I think he's great in
this portrayal but it doesn't seem like
an accurate biopic depiction of how he
actually made but it serves a movie
really well I like how they compared him
to Michael Cera okay he is the more a
high-caliber actor Michael Cera
because they're both awkward characters
all the time no matter what they do I'm
sure they see each other at audition
like yeah more than more when they had
to actually
vision for stuff instead of being
offered and stuff they probably saw each
other a lot in the waiting room and like
that guy yeah that guy again I see him
hey speaking of transitions subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell it'll do you justice Brienne is
Miss movies on YouTube mr. vennett I'm
having a hard time turning on Twitter
yeah miss underscore boobies on
Instagram and snapchat follow her
they're really long so patreon outfit my
name sorry did you go follow us on
patreon join the patreon community
it'll be beneficial I'm getting dizzy
this is not a carnival I'm about to
vomit have a good day